SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO, GIL ARCHULETA,
ASHBY, ATKINS, BECKER,
BLAKESPEAR, BRADFORD CABALLERO,
CORTESI DALI. ODD. TOO AGIN
GLASER GONZALEZ. GROVE HURTADO.
JONES LAIRD, LIMÓN MAGUIRE
MENJIVAR MIN. NEW MIN. WHEN NILO
OCHO PAD PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO,
SEYARTO SKINNER, SMALL WORK.
CUEVAS STERN, HUMBERG WAHAB
WIENER WILK. MEMBERS OF QUORUM
IS PRESENT. WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY, PLEASE RISE.
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR CHAP CHAPLAIN,
SISTER MICHELLE GARMAN, AFTER
WHICH WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU TO
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
GRACIOUS AND EVERY LOVING GOD,
WE PRAY FOR THE STRENGTH AND
COURAGE TO CONTINUE TO ENSURE
THE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS AND
ESSENTIAL NEEDS OF OUR PEOPLE IN
THIS TIME AND PLACE. WITH YOUR
HELP. WE WILL WORK TOGETHER TO
ACCOMPLISH OUR DEEPEST DESIRES
FOR LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
AND IN THE WORDS OF JUDY
CHICAGO. THEN ALL THAT HAS BEEN
DIVIDED, WILL MERGE. AND THEN
COMPASSION WILL BE WEDDED TO
POWER. AND THEN SOFTNESS WILL
COME TO A WORLD THAT IS HARSH
AND UNKIND. AND THEN BOTH MEN
AND WOMEN WILL BE GENTLE. AND
THEN BOTH WOMEN AND MEN WILL BE
STRONG. AND THEN NÓ PERSON WILL
BE SUBJECT TO ANOTHER'S WILL.
AND THEN ALL WILL BE RICH AND
FREE AND VARIED. AND THEN ALL
WILL SHARE EQUALLY IN THE
EARTH'S ABUNDANCE. AND THEN ALL
WILL CARE FOR THE SICK AND THE
WEAK AND THE OLD. AND THEN ALL
WILL NOURISH THE YOUNG. AND THEN
ALL WILL LIVE IN HARMONY WITH
EACH OTHER AND THE EARTH. AND
THEN EVERYWHERE WILL BE CALLED
TO EDEN ONCE AGAIN. MERCIFUL GOD
, MAY WE HAVE THE STRENGTH AND
COURAGE TO WORK TOWARDS THOSE
ENDS? AMEN. MEMBERS TO JOIN ME
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I
PLEDGE THEE I BELIEVE AMERICA.
JUST. MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SENATOR DE RAZO AND SENATOR
ATKINS WILL BE RECOGNIZED AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
WELCOME DOCTOR ROBERT Kò ROSS
AND MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENDOWMENT TO THE SENATE CHAMBER.
TODAY WE ARE CELEBRATING DOCTOR
ROSS, WHO? AFTER MANY YEARS OF
PUBLIC SERVICE IS EMBARKING ON
RETIREMENT. HE HAS AN EXTREMELY
EXTRAORDINARY RESUME. AFTER
RECEIVING HIS UNDERGRADUATE AND
MASTER'S IN PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION AND MEDICAL
DEGREES FROM THE UNIVERSITY AND
IN PHILADELPHIA, PENNSYLVANIA
AND PHILADELPHIA DOCTOR BOSS
BEGAN HIS CAREER IN PUBLIC
SERVICE FIRST SERVING AS
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND IS COMMISSIONER OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IN THE CITY OF
PHILADELPHIA. HE WAS THEN
APPOINTED AS PRESIDENT AND CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT IN
SEPTEMBER OF 2000. UNDER HIS
LEADERSHIP, THE ENDOWMENT HAS
AWARDED MORE THAN 22,000 GRANTS.
TOTALLY ALMOST $3 BILLION TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. HE HAS
UPLIFTED A NEW VISION OF HEALTH
EQUITY. WE'RE ALL PEOPLES. ALL
COMMUNITIES HAVE A RIGHT TO
DEVELOP THEIR FULL POTENTIAL.
THIS INCLUDES ADVOCATING AND
FUNDING EFFORTS IN SUPPORT OF A
HEALTH FOR ALL CAMPAIGN. I
HELPED IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
LEAD WHICH I AM PROUD TO SAY
EXPANDED HEALTH COVERAGE FOR 1.2
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. HE
CHAMPIONED STRENGTHENING
DIVERSITY IN THE HEALTH
WORKFORCE. HE ADVANCED, WELLNESS
DRIVEN SCHOOL CLIMATE REFORMS,
IMPROVED HEALTH ADVOCACY FOR
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN OF COLOR,
AND HE PROVIDED FOR HEALTH
ORIENTED CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM. HE WAS ALSO A FOUNDING
BOARD MEMBER OF COVERED
CALIFORNIA AND SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENTED THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT IN CALIFORNIA. MORE RECENTLY
, HE SERVED AS CHAIR OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY TASK FORCE ON
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION
AND DEVELOPED A STRATEGIC ROAD
MAP FOR THE COUNTY TO REFORM THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM BY
SUPPORTING HEALTH FOCUSED
STRATEGIES TO REDUCE
INCARCERATION. IN 2021 DOCTOR
ROSS WORKED IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS TO RAISE
THREE $100 MILLION FOR A FIRST
EVER SOCIAL BOND BY TO BE IN
CALIFORNIA, WAS WHICH WAS
DESIGNED TO BUILD SUPPORT FOR
GRASSROOTS ACTIVISTS IN SOCIAL
JUSTICE THROUGH ALL OF THESE
EFFORTS, IN ADDITION TO HIS WORK
AS A PUBLIC HEALTH ADMINISTRATOR
AND CLINICIAN, DOCTOR, ROSS HAS
EXEMPLIFIED A TRUE COMMITMENT TO
STRENGTHENING CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO ENSURING HEALTH
FOR ALL FOR EVERYONE. HE LED,
BROAD PHILANTHROPIC AND
NONPROFIT COLLABORATION BY
INVITING TO COME TOGETHER. HE
CONNECTED THE DOTS BETWEEN
EQUITY, DIVERSITY AND HEALTH.
HE'S BEEN ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
COMMUNITY AND PROFESSIONAL
ACTIVITIES, BOTH AT THE LOCAL
AND THE NATIONAL LEVEL. HE
SERVED ON THE BOARDS OF GRANT
MAKERS HEALTH, SAN DIEGO UNITED
WAY AND THE JACKIE ROBINSON YM
èC, A IS A DIPLOMAT OF THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS,
CHAIRMAN OF THE NATIONAL BOOST
FOR KIDS INITIATIVE AND SERVED
ON THE PRESIDENT'S SUMMIT FOR
AMERICA'S FUTURE. HE WAS HONORED
BY THE COUNCIL ON FOUNDATIONS AS
DISTINGUISHED GRANT MAKER AND
ALSO RECEIVED THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC HEALTH ASSOCIATION'S
HIGHEST AWARD IN 2020. DOCTOR
ROSS MOST RECENTLY SERVED AS
STANFORD UNIVERSITY'S
DISTINGUISHED VISITING PROFESSOR
FOR THE 2020. ACADEMIC CALENDAR
ON A PERSONAL NOTE. HE HAS BEEN
A VERY GOOD FRIEND TO ME, ALWAYS
PROVIDING ADVICE, LAUGHTER,
VISION, YOU NAME IT, HE'S THERE.
HE'S THERE. FOR MANY OF US, HE
HAS TOUCHED THE HEARTS AND THE
LIVES OF DIRECTLY OF HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE. HE IS NOT TOO HIGH UP IN
HIS STATUS TO BE MEETING WITH
FORMALLY INCARCERATED TO BE
MEETING WITH YOUTH WHO WANT TO
COME, ORGANIZERS. HE IS THERE
FOR EVERYONE, AND THEREFORE HE
HAS PERSONALLY TOUCHED THE LIVES
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE AND HELP
THEM TO BECOME LEADERS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. HE WILL NOW HAVE TIME
TO SPEND. WITH FAMILY AND WITH
OTHER AND FRIENDS, AND I HOPE HE
REALLY GETS TO ENJOY HIMSELF,
ALTHOUGH I KNOW WE WILL BE
CALLING ON HIM AGAIN. COLLEAGUES
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING
DOCTOR, ROBERT Kò ROSS FOR HIS
DEDICATION TO SERVING CALIFORNIA
AND AMERICA AND WISHING HIM A
HAPPY RETIREMENT.
CONGRATULATIONS. INTERACTING TO
YOUR REC ON THIS ISSUE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR PRESIDENT, AND I
ACTUALLY THINK MY COLLEAGUE SAID
IT ALL. UH AND IT'S A LOT. UH,
HE DESERVES INCREDIBLE
RECOGNITION FOR SO MUCH, BUT I
PARTICULARLY WANTED TO THANK HIM
FOR A FEW THINGS. ONE SHE
MENTIONED THAT HE WAS OUR
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AT THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO, AND I HAD JUST BECOME A
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER. AND WE HAD,
UH, SOME ISSUES WITH OUR, UH,
LESBIAN AND MEN'S COMMUNITY
CENTER IN WHICH THERE WAS A
TRANSITION OF POWER, A NONPROFIT
A NEW BOARD AND HE REALLY
STEPPED IN TO HELP SAVE THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES PROGRAM
AT THE GÂY AND LESBIAN CENTER
AND ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
THERE. I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THAT ALL THOSE YEARS AGO, BUT
THAT WASN'T ENOUGH. THEN HE WENT
ON TO, UM, SERVE. UH, OBVIOUSLY
A COW ENDOWMENT. I WANNA SAY
THANK YOU TO THE BOARD MEMBERS
THAT ARE HERE ALSO, THE BUILDING
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES PROGRAM WAS
A 10 YEAR ONE. DOLLARS
COMPREHENSIVE COMMUNITY CHANGE
IN IT. INITIATIVE LAUNCHED BY
THE ENDOWMENT IN 2010 TO
ADVOCATE STATE POLICY AND REALLY
FOCUS ON 14 TRANSFORM AND FOCUS
ON 14 OF CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES DEVASTATED BY HEALTH
INEQUITIES. AND I WAS A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER, AND THEY TOOK ON
ONE OF OUR COMMUNITY. CITY
HEIGHTS 90,000 PEOPLE IN ONE
COMMUNITY, ONE OF THE MOST
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES IN THE
COUNTRY, UH, MORE THAN ALMOST
200 LANGUAGES AND DIALECTS
SPOKEN SUDANESE, SOMALI,
ERITREAN ON AND ON, AND THEY
REALLY EMBRACED THAT COMMUNITY
FOR MORE THAN A DECADE, UH, THEN
WENT ON TO WORK WITH MID CITY
CAN ANOTHER NONPROFIT. THESE
ORGANIZATIONS DOING REAL WORK
ON? GROUND THAT NEEDED
RECOGNITION BY A FOUNDATION, UH
BY A LEADER THAT UNDERSTOOD THAT
THEY REALLY NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO SERVICES AND TO
HAVE A VOICE AND POWER IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. AND THAT'S WHAT CAL
ENDOWMENT DID FOR THEM IN
RECOGNIZING CITY HEIGHTS AS ONE
OF THOSE COMMUNITIES, I WOULD,
UM LIKE TO ALSO, UH, ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT BOTH THE GOVERNOR AND HIS
APPOINTMENT TO YOU OF YOU TO THE
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COMMISSION,
AND CERTAINLY THE APPOINTMENT OF
THE SENATE UNDER PRO TEM
STEINBERG, UH, APPOINTING YOU TO
COVERED CALIFORNIA WERE WISE
DECISIONS, BECAUSE, UH, OF AN
INDIVIDUAL THAT CARES SO MUCH,
UH, YOU HEARD THE LONG LIST OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND ENGAGEMENT.
ALL OF THAT WAS WORK. IT WASN'T
AS A FIGUREHEAD. IT WASN'T YOU
KNOW, UM, AS SOMETHING TO MAKE A
RESUME, LOOK GOOD. IT INVOLVED
REAL WORK WITH REAL PEOPLE ON
THE GROUND. AND I WOULD SAY, UH,
IN ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF ALL OF ALL
OF THAT, I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE EXPERTISE, YOUR
INTELLIGENCE BUT ALSO YOUR HEART
AND TO THE BOARD THAT ALLOWED
YOU TO, UH, BE IN THAT ROLE TO
DO SO MUCH GOOD FOR SO MANY
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA. I WISH YOU
THE BEST IN RETIREMENT. I WISH
YOU THE BEST AT THE OPPORTUNITY
OF ACTUALLY DOING IT, AND WE
SHALL SEE IF THAT COMES ASKED.
BUT THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF MY
COMMUNITY IN SAN DIEGO, BUT ALSO
ALL OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. WE WANT TO THANK DOCTOR
ROSS FOR HIS STEADFAST,
VISIONARY LEADERSHIP TO ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. THOSE MEMBERS WHO
ARE WISHING TO TAKE A PICTURE.
WE'LL PAUSE AT THIS TIME AND
AFFORD YOU THAT OPPORTUNITY.
ALL RIGHT, CONTINUED PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR. NEXT STEP IS
SENATOR HURTADO. OK? THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO RECOGNIZE THE MAYOR
MCFARLAND, SAUL LEÓN. MAYOR AYON
HAS BEEN A RELENTLESS FIGHTER
AND ADVOCATE FOR THE PEOPLE OF
MCFARLAND. THE MAYOR HAS ALSO
BEEN AN EXCEPTIONAL PARTNER IN
S¼ Dð 16 AS WE STRIVE TO BRING
WATER SECURITY, PUBLIC SAFETY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ADDITIONAL
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES TO THE
PEOPLE OF OUR REGION. UH, HE IS
JOINED THIS AFTERNOON, UH, UP IN
THE GALLERY, BUT WITH THE UM
MCFARLAND HIGH SCHOOL EARLY
COLLEGE EDUCATION èC Tð E
CAREER TRAINING. EDUCATORS AND
IT IS A PLEASURE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
HIM TODAY ON THIS FLOOR. SO I
BUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES. I KNOW THAT THIS IS,
UH MCFARLANE IS DEFINITELY IN
SENATOR HURTADO'S DISTRICT. BUT
THIS IS AN EXTRAORDINARY MAN
THAT STANDS BEFORE YOU. HE IS
THIRD IN LINE OF 12 KIDS. HE IS
A U S¼ A, UH, WRESTLER, UM, MADE
IT TO THE TRIALS AND HAD A
SENSATIONAL VICTORY AT
CENTENNIAL GARDEN. AND HE
ACTUALLY DID THE U S¼ OLYMPIC
TRAINING Tð AND TRIALS AND THEN
CAME BACK TO MCFARLANE, WHERE HE
WANTED TO INVEST IN THE NEXT
GENERATION SO THAT THEY COULD
STAY OUT OF THE I GUESS THE
PATHWAY TO, UH, PENITENTIARY.
JUST GOING TO SAY IT. THERE'S A
LOT OF KIDS THAT DON'T HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES IN MCFARLANE AND
THIS MAN STANDING BEHIND ME
CREATES THOSE OPPORTUNITIES. AND
HE DOES IT WITH A, UM I DON'T
WANT TO SAY WITH AN IRON FIST,
BUT HE HE GIVES THEM PRIVILEGE
AND OPPORTUNITY AND SHOWS THEM
WHAT SUCCESS LOOKS LIKE, BUT HE
ALSO HOLDS THEM ACCOUNTABLE. AND
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING. OUR
YOUTH, UM, MISSES TODAY, AND HE
REALLY WRAPS HIS ARMS AROUND A
WHOLE COMMUNITY OF YOUTH. AND
HE'S THE FATHER OF THE ENTIRE
HIGH SCHOOL. UH, YOUTH, AND I
JUST WANT YOU TO TELL YOU THAT
HE IS REALLY THE PRIDE OF
MCFARLANE. HE'S A MAYOR WHO
FIGHTS FOR WATER. HE FIGHTS FOR
HIS CONSTITUENTS. HE FIGHTS FOR
PARKS AND SAFE PLACES FOR KIDS
TO PLAY, AND HE REALLY IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY INDIVIDUAL. SO I'M
GOING TO SORT OF ADOPT HIM
TODAY, ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUE
WHO SHE REALLY REPRESENTS HIM,
BUT I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I WAS
ABLE TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT THIS
IS AN EXTRAORDINARY MAN STANDING
ON THIS FLOOR WITH YOU GUYS
TODAY. THANK YOU. CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. WELCOME TO MAYOR.
MEMBERS IF YOU LIKE TO TAKE A
PICTURE, WE'LL PAUSE AT THIS
TIME AND AFFORD YOU THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU CONTINUING UNDER
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR. NEXT UP
IS SENATOR LAIRD. PURPOSES OF
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. IT IS MY PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE TO YOU THE CAL POLY
SAN LOUIS OBISPO AGRICULTURAL
LEADERSHIP CLASS WHO ARE JOINING
US TODAY FROM THE GALLERY. YOU
CAN SEE THEM STANDING. BECAUSE
OF THEIR IMPRESSIVE BACKGROUNDS
AND ACADEMIC ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
THESE STUDENTS WERE SELECTED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM AND TO
RESEARCH SIGNIFICANT ISSUES
IMPACTING CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE. UH, THIS PROGRAM
INCLUDES THE CLASS VISITING THE
STATE CAPITOL AND SURROUNDING
AGENCIES FOR FIRSTHAND EXPOSURE
TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF PUBLIC
POLICY, WHICH INCLUDES WIT,
WITNESSING US TODAY FROM THE
GALLERY. UH, SINCE ESTABLISHED
IN 2001, THE CLASS HAS VISITED
US ANNUALLY, AND I'M PLEASED TO
REPORT THAT SEVERAL ALUMS HAVE
BEEN CHOSEN OVER THE YEARS FOR
INTERNSHIPS IN THE STATE
CAPITAL. ALSO JOINING THE
STUDENTS IS THEIR PROFESSOR
ANASTASIA TASK WHO SHOULD BE
CONGRATULATED FOR HER DEDICATION
TO DEVELOPING THE NEXT
GENERATION OF AGRICULTURAL
LEADERS. UH, SENATORS, PLEASE
GIVE A WARM WELCOME TO THE STATE
SENATE TO THE AG LEADERSHIP
CLASS OF COW PARK. MHM. WELCOME
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE CENTER.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS. NOW WE'RE
MOVING TO MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED AT REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR FEBRUARY 26 2024
THROUGH FEBRUARY 29 2024 WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. FIRST UP IS
GOVERNMENT APPOINTMENTS FILE
ITEM ONE, SENATOR GROVE. SHE'S
PREPARED. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES UM, FILE
ITEM. ONE IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
GREGORY YOUNG FOR APPOINTMENT TO
THIS AS SENIOR DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION. UH MR YOUNG HAS A
LONG CAREER OF FINANCIAL
SERVICES. HE'S HELD NUMEROUS
EXECUTIVE POSITIONS COVERING
COMMUNITY LENDING, RETAIL SALES,
MARKET GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT
AND A CORPORATE SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ENTITIES SUCH
AS. UM BANK OF AMERICA, WELLS
FARGO AND AMERICAN EXPRESS AND
CONTRARY TO WHAT YOU MIGHT
THINK, BECAUSE OF THE RUN WE HAD
ON A BANK. LAST YEAR OR THE YEAR
BEFORE HE HAS ASSURED US OVER
AND OVER AGAIN IN THE COMMITTEE
HEARING THAT, UM OUR FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS ARE HEALTHY AND
THEY DO HAVE PLANS TO KEEP THEM
HEALTHY. AND SO I JUST URGE AND
I VOTE BECAUSE THIS, UH HE WAS
CONFIRMED ON THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON FEBRUARY 21ST TO THE 50 VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM, SENATOR
GLASER. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK WITH MR YOUNG AND I
CONCUR WITH THE RULES COMMITTEE
REPRESENTATIVE THAT HE DOES COME
WELL PREPARED TO OVERSEE THE
SAFETY OF OUR FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS. UH, HE UNDERSTANDS
THE UH, THAT OUR GROWTH AND
PROSPERITY AND OUR ECONOMY IS
DEPENDENT UPON THAT. UM HE'S
SOMEONE THAT HAS ASSURED ME AND
I BELIEVE HIM IT IT'S QUITE
SENSITIVE TO THE ISSUE OF SMALL
BUSINESS AND RESPONSIBLE LENDING
. AND I KNOW HE'LL DO A GOOD JOB
OVERSEEING BANKS, BROKERS AND
COMMERCIAL LENDERS. AND WITH
THAT, I CONC RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A SUPPORT OF, UH, HIS
NOMINATION. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? YOU SEEN NONE.
SECRETARY OF POLICE CALLED THE
ROLL. ALAN HIY ALBERTO GIL. AYE,
ARCHULETA. ASHBY. HIY ATKINS.
HØI BECKER. ALL RIGHT,
BLAKESPEAR. HØI BRADFORD. HØI
CABALLERO HIY CORTESI. ALL
RIGHT, DALLY. AYE, DAD. AYE,
DURAZO. HØI EDMUND. BLAZER. HØI
GONZALEZ. UH, GROVE. HIY JONES.
AYE, LAIRD. AYE, LEMON. MAGUIRE.
AYE, MENJIVAR. AYE, MEN. NEWMAN.
AY WHEN HØI NILO. IY, WHICH ARE
BOTH HØI, PA. PORTANTINO BROTH.
AYE, RUBIO. AYE, SEYARTO. UH,
SKINNER. SMALLER CUEVAS. HIY
STERN. HØI HUMBERG. AYE. WELL,
HÌ. AYE. WIENER IY WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA. MON. LIMÓN MEN. BUT
THE FORTINO SKINNER. HØI. I 34
NÓ ZERO. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON THE SENATE THIRD
READING. FIRST UP IS FILE ITEM
FOUR. SENATOR HUMBERG. ARE YOU
PREPARED? I AM SECRETARY YOU MAY
READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 98 BY SENATOR UMBERG
RELATIVE TO PUBLIC HEALTH. TO
REMEMBER. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES, I RISE
AND ASK FOR YOUR RECOGNITION AND
SUPPORT OF S¼ èC R 98, WHICH
MEMORIALIZES THE MONTH OF MARCH
AS TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY
AWARENESS MONTH. Tð B S¼ ARE A
MAJOR ISSUE. 2.8 MILLION
AMERICANS SUSTAINED TRAUMATIC
BRAIN INJURY ANNUALLY. JUST NINE
IN JUST 2022 ALONE OVER 84,000
CALIFORNIANS WERE HOSPITALIZED
AND OVER 161,000 VISITED THE
EMERGENCY ROOM DUE TO Tð B. I
THIS DOESN'T JUST IMPACT ADULTS,
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF HEALTH ABOUT
475,000 CHILDREN SUSTAIN A TBI
ANNUALLY. THESE INJURIES CAN BE
SUSTAINED ANYWHERE IN THE
MILITARY AND COMBAT SPORTS, OR
EVEN AT HOME. 11 NOTABLE ITEM IS
THAT Tð B I S¼ ARE ACTUALLY EVEN
MORE FREQUENT IN THE MILITARY
TODAY THAN THEY USED TO BE. UM
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT THERE ARE
FEWER FATALITIES BECAUSE OF
BETTER BODY ARMOR AND
PROTECTION. BUT THE BAD NEWS IS
THERE ARE MORE Tð B. I S¼ IN
FACT, ACCORDING TO THE U S¼
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIR
NEARLY 414,000 VETERANS
SUSTAINED A TBI FROM THE YEAR
2000 TO 2019 TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURIES CAN NEGATIVELY IMPACT A
PERSON'S ABILITY TO HOLD A JOB,
MAINTAIN RELATIONSHIPS OR EVEN
CARE FOR THEMSELVES. Tð B. I CAN
BE DEVASTATING TO A PERSON'S
FAMILY AWARENESS, EARLY
SCREENING, DIAGNOSIS AND CARE
FOR CALIFORNIAN SUSTAINED A
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY ARE
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT LIFELONG
HEALTH FOR CALIFORNIANS LIVING
WITH Tð B. I IN THEIR
CAREGIVERS, UH Tð B. I IS OFTEN
NOT DIAGNOSED, UH IMMEDIATELY
AND WHICH CAUSES FURTHER HARM
AND DAMAGE. THEREFORE S¼ èC, A
98 PROCLAIMS THE MONTH OF MARCH
CLAIMS MARCH IS TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY AWARENESS MONTH TO
EDUCATE AND SPREAD AWARENESS TO
THE PUBLIC AND THE LARGE IMPACT
THAT Tð B. I S¼ HAVE IN A
SIZABLE PORTION OF OUR STATE'S
POPULATION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE HERE IN XAN MEMBERS? THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS MEASURE? HEARING XAN EYES
34 KNOWS ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. NOW MEMBERS. WE'RE
MOVING ON THE FOUL ITEM 10. ONCE
AGAIN, SENATOR UMBERG. HE'S
PREPARED SECRETARY MAY REID SEND
A CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 112 BY
SENATOR UMBERG RELATIVE TO BLACK
MUNDE. NUREMBERG THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES, I RISE
AND ASK FOR YOUR RECOGNITION
SUPPORT OF S¼ èC R 112, WHICH
MORALIZES WEDNESDAY, MARCH 6TH
AS BLACK BALLOON DAY A DAY TO
RECOGNIZE THE LIVES LOST TO
OVERDOSE FROM OPIOIDS. OPIOID
OVERDOSE IS A LEADING CAUSE OF
ACCIDENTAL DEATH WITH IMPACTS OF
WHAT THE IMPACTS OF FENTANYL
ONLY MAKING MATTERS WORSE,
ACCORDING TO THE èC, Dð èC
MORE THAN 112,000 PEOPLE HAVE
DIED DUE TO DRUG OVERDOSE OR
POISONING OVER THE PAST YEAR,
2021 AND SYNTHETIC OPIOIDS WERE
INVOLVED IN 80% OF DRUG INDUCED
DEATHS OF THOSE AGED 14 TO 23.
TODAY MORE AMERICANS ARE LIKELY
TO DIE OF AN OVERDOSE FROM
OPIOIDS THAN THEY ARE FROM A CAR
ACCIDENT OR FROM A GUN AND
FENTANYL IS A LEADER IN CAUSING
THESE PREVENTABLE DEATHS WITH
THAT, SAID A RECENT STUDY IN
2022 FOUND THAT ONLY AROUND 47%
OF YOUNG AMERICANS AND AROUND
31% OF TEENS CONSIDER THEMSELVES
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT FENTANYL.
PREVENTION IS THE BEST TOOL. TO
ADDRESS DRUG ABUSE. I'M SURE WE
ALL KNOW SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE HARM CAUSED BY
OPIOIDS. S¼ èC R 112 PROCLAIMS
MARCH 6TH 2024 IS BLACK BALLOON
DAY TO COMMEMORATE THE LIVES
LOST TO OPIOID OVERDOSE AND
BRING PUBLIC ATTENTION TO THE
ATROCITIES OF THE OVERDOSES
TAKING PLACE IN CALIFORNIA. I
URGE YOU I VOTE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM, SENATOR RUBIO THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF S¼ èC R
112 AND I WANNA THANK THE GREAT
SENATOR FROM ORANGE COUNTY FOR
INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE, LOS ANGELES COUNTY HAS
EXPERIENCED A DRAMATIC UPSWING
AND OVERDOSE FROM FENTANYL AND
ACROSS OUR STATE AND OUR COUNTRY
, ACCORDING TO THE L, A COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
ACCIDENTAL FENTANYL DEATHS
INCREASED OVER 1500% BETWEEN
2016 AND 2022, INCLUDING IN MY
YOU MY DISTRICT, ALMOST 500
DEATHS IN THE SAME GOA VALLEY.
AS A LONGTIME ADVOCATE FOR
PREVENTION OF ACCIDENTAL OPIATE
OVERDOSE. IT BREAKS MY HEART
EVERY TIME WE SIT WITH FAMILIES
WHO'VE LOST A LOVED ONE. WE HEAR
THE STORIES ALL THE TIME IN THE
NEWS, AND IT JUST KEEPS GOING
AND GOING. WE'RE LOSING TOO MANY
OF OUR CHILDREN, UH IN AWARENESS
IS IMPORTANT. AND AS A GREAT
SENATOR STATED EARLIER
PREVENTION IS THE BEST TOOL AND
WE NEED TO BRING AWARENESS AND
MAKE SURE THAT PARENTS ARE
VIGILANT. ALL OF US ARE VIGILANT
BECAUSE IT WILL CONTINUE ALSO,
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING
THIS RESOLUTION DECLARED. 6 2024
AS BLACK BALLOON DAY A DAY TO
REMEMBER AND CELEBRATE LIFE'S
LOSS TO OVERDOSES BY OPIOID. I
ALSO URGE AND I VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE HEARING? SEE NONE.
SENATOR UMBERG. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? UM I SIMPLY ASK URGE,
AND I VOTE. MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING THE UNITED UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL TO THIS MEASURE?
HEARING IN X NÓ ICE 34 KNOWS
ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO FOUL ITEM
SIX. SENATOR NILO HE IS READY.
SECRETARY MAY RE SENATORS 109 BY
SENATOR LINDO RELATIVE TO
COLORECTAL CANCER AWARENESS
MONTH THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I
RISE TO RECOGNIZE THE MONTH OF
MARCH 2024 AS COLORECTAL CANCER
AWARENESS. COLORECTAL CANCER IS
THE SECOND LEASING LEADING CAUSE
OF CANCER DEATHS IN THE UNITED
STATES AMONG MEN AND WOMEN
COMBINED AND IS ESTIMATED TO BE
THE NUMBER ONE KILLER FOR PEOPLE
AGES 20 TO 49 BY 2030. AFRICAN
AMERICANS ARE 20% MORE LIKELY TO
BE DIAGNOSED WITH COLORECTAL
CANCER AND ARE ABOUT 40% MORE
LIKELY TO DIE FROM THE DISEASE,
THEN OTHER GROUPS, COLORECTAL
CANCER IS ALSO EXPECTED TO
ACCOUNT FOR 11% OF CANCER DEATHS
AMONG HISPANIC MEN AND 9% OF
CANCER DEATHS AMONG HISPANIC
WOMEN. IN 2023 ALONE. THERE WERE
APPROXIMATELY 150 THREE NEW
CASES AND ABOUT 52,500 DEATHS
FROM COLORECTAL CANCER IN THE
UNITED STATES. NOW AS DEADLY AS
THIS DISEASE IS, IT IS ONE OF
THE FEW TYPES OF CANCERS THAT
CAN BE PREVENTED WITH TIMELY
SCREENINGS. BUT ONE IN THREE
ELIGIBLE AMERICANS ARE NOT UP TO
DATE ON THEIR SCREENINGS.
RAISING AWARENESS ABOUT
COLORECTAL CANCER. UH, ALONG
WITH OFFERING EDUCATION ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF EARLY DETECTION.
AND TIMELY SCREENINGS. COULD
POTENTIALLY SAVE THE LIVES OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY IN
RAISING AWARENESS TO THIS DEADLY
DISEASE BY VOTING I ON S¼ èC R
109 RECOGNIZING THE MONTH OF
MARCH 2020 2020 24 AS COLO
RECTAL CANCER AWARENESS MONTH.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
HEARING AND SEEING NONE MEMBERS.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO THIS
MEASURE? HERE IN QINAN EYES 34
NOSE ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. NOW WE'RE MOVING BACK
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. MR
PRESIDENT FOR THAT. MR
PRESIDENT. PRIVILEGE TO FLOOR.
I'M SORRY TO THE FLOOR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. JOINING ME TODAY
IN THE GALLERY. IN CONNECTION
WITH THIS RESOLUTION IS MR DÂN
DRY DOCK. SHOCKLEY A RETIRED
NAVY OPERATION DESERT STORM,
ENDURING FREEDOM AND IRAQI
FREEDOM VETERAN AND A 12 YEAR
HEREDITARY COLON CANCER. COR I
ALMOST SAID SURVIVOR. HE'S A
WARRIOR. HE'S UP IN THE GALLERY.
HE IS A RESIDENT OF MY DISTRICT,
AND HE'S JOINED TODAY BY OTHER
COLORECTAL CANCER. CANCER
AWARENESS ADVOCATES, INCLUDING A
MEMBER OF THE GAULT CITY
COUNCIL. IN THE GALLERY. WELCOME
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. AND
BEFORE WE MOVE BACK TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS, WE WANT TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE
THE BIRTHDAY CELEBRATION OF ONE
OF OUR MEMBERS. SENATOR HURTADO
IS CELEBRATING HER BIRTHDAY
TODAY. HAPPY BIRTHDAY. LET'S
WISH HER A HAPPY BIRTHDAY. NOW
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
NOW IT IS THE TIME FOR
ADJOURNMENT AND MEMORIES.
SENATOR ATKINS THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A
VERY GOOD FRIEND AND A MENTOR,
GERALYN JERRY DIL KNOW WHO
PASSED AWAY ON FEBRUARY 14TH.
SHE WAS 87. JERRY WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN SAN DIEGO. SHE SERVED
IN THE AIR FORCE FROM 1958 UNTIL
1961 WHEN SHE RECEIVED A
DISHONORABLE DISCHARGE AFTER BE
BEING INVESTIGATED FOR BEING GÂY
AN AFFRONT TO HER CIVIL RIGHTS
AND SERVICE TO OUR NATION. NEVER
ONE TO BE KEPT DOWN. SHE FOUGHT
SUCCESSFULLY TO HAVE HER
DISCHARGE CHANGED FROM
DISHONORABLE TO HONORABLE. JUST
ONE OF THE MANY FIGHTS FOR THE L
GB Tð Q, PLUS RIGHTS THAT SHE
WOULD UNDERTAKE IN HER LIFE, AND
SHE'S PROUDLY DISPLAYED ON THE
WALL IN OUR COMMUNITY CENTER FOR
HER SERVICE TO COUNTRY AS A
VETERAN. SHE HELPED FOUND THE
FIRST ORGANIZED SAN DIEGO PRIDE
MARCH IN 1975 BACK WHEN THE
EVENT NUMBERED ABOUT 400 PEOPLE
TO PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE, LAST
YEAR'S SAN DIEGO PRIDE PARADE
DREW MORE THAN THREE 100,000
SPECTATORS. THE GROWTH OF SAN
DIEGO PRIDE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
POSSIBLE WITHOUT EARLY ACTIVISTS
LIKE JERRY, WHO RISK THEIR VERY
CAREERS TO FIGHT FOR THEIR RIGHT
TO LIVE AND LOVE OPENLY. SHE
SERVED AS THE FIRST FEMALE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE GÂY
CENTER IN 1975, A POSITION SHE
HELD FOR A FEW YEARS. IN FACT,
IT WAS AT HER INSISTENCE THAT
THE SINNER ADDED LESBIAN AND
COMMUNITY INTO ITS NAME,
BECOMING THE LESBIAN AND GÂY
MEN'S COMMUNITY CENTER. SHE
PARTICIPATED IN LOCAL DEMOCRATIC
POLITICS SERVED AS THE PRESIDENT
OF THE SAN DIEGO DEMOCRATIC CLUB
, NOW CALLED SAN DIEGO DEMOCRATS
FOR EQUALITY. UH FROM 1987 TO
1991. IN FACT, I MET HER IN 1987
. WHEN I JOINED THE CLUB. SHE
WAS CO-CHAIR OF US THE STATE'S
DEMOCRATIC L GB Tð Q CAUCUS FROM
1989 THROUGH 1991. HER TIRELESS
ACTIVISM IS PART OF THE REASON
THAT I'M STANDING IN FRONT OF
YOU HERE TODAY. SHE NEVER
STOPPED WORKING TO GET WOMEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE L GB Tð Q PLUS
COMMUNITY ELECTED TO OFFICE.
SUPPORTED CHRISTINE KEHOE WHEN
SHE RAN FOR SAN DIEGO CITY
COUNCIL AND BECAME SAN DIEGO'S
FIRST OPEN L GB Tð Q PLUS
ELECTED OFFICIAL, CHRIS KEHOE'S
VICTORY PAVED THE WAY FOR ME AND
SO MANY OTHERS, INCLUDING MANY
OF OUR LEGISLATIVE COLLEAGUES.
NOW THANKS TO JERRY, AND
ADVOCATES LIKE HER SAN DIEGO
COUNTY HAS MORE L GB Tð Q PLUS
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES OF ANY
COUNTY IN THE NATION. I COULD
FEEL COUNTLESS PAGES DESCRIBING
EVERY BOARD THAT SHE SERVED ON
EVERY HONOR SHE WAS AWARDED FOR
HER SERVICE TO SAN DIEGO TO THE
WOMEN'S COMMUNITY AND TO THE L,
GB Tð Q, PLUS COMMUNITY AND
EVERY LIFE SHE CHANGED THROUGH
HER WORK FOR EQUALITY FOR L, GB
Tð Q PEOPLE. BUT I WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT JERRY IS KNOWN NOT
JUST FOR HER ACCOLADES AND HER
ACTIVISM BUT FOR HER HEART. I
HAD THE INCREDIBLE HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE OF KNOWING JERRY
PERSONALLY FOR 37 YEARS, SHE WAS
A FRIEND, A MENTOR AND A
STEADFAST SUPPORTER, SOMEONE
THAT I COULD ALWAYS GO TO FOR
ADVICE AND AN ENCOURAGING WORD.
SHE WAS A TRUE OPTIMIST WITH A
QUICK WIT AND A HEARTY LAUGH AND
INCREDIBLE STORYTELLER. SHE WAS
WICKED SMART, AND SHE LOVED TO
DANCE. I WAS ABLE TO GO TO SAN
DIEGO TO VISIT HER THE DAY THAT
SHE PASSED AWAY. IT'S A MEMORY
THAT I WILL ALWAYS CHERISH AS
DIFFICULT AS IT WAS FROM THE
SUNDAY THAT, UH SHE, UH, ENDED
UP IN THE HOSPITAL. HER ROOM WAS
NEVER EMPTY. THROUGH FEBRUARY,
14TH THE DAY THAT SHE LEFT US
THERE WAS A STEADY STREAM OF
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THERE TO SEE
HER AND TO SAY GOODBYE AND TO
TELL HER WHAT SHE MEANT TO EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF US. SHE LEFT AN
IMPORTANT MARK ON MY LIFE AND
THE LIVES OF SO MANY OTHERS.
IT'S MY SINCERE HOPE THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE CELEBRATING HER
LEGACY. REMEMBERING HER THROUGH
THE CAUSES. SHE DEDICATED HER
LIFE TO COLLEAGUES. I ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN TODAY IN MEMORY OF MY
FRIEND JERRY DIL, NOT A
TRAILBLAZING CHAMPION FOR THE L
GB Tð Q PLUS COMMUNITY, THE
WOMEN'S COMMUNITY AND MY
TREASURED FRIEND. THANK YOU. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. WE EXTEND OUR MOST
SINCERE CONDOLENCES AND ASK THAT
YOU ALL RIGHT, SENATOR LAIRD ON
THIS MEASURE AS WELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MR PRESIDENT. IT IS
HARD TO ADD TO WHAT THE PRO TEM
EMERITUS DID, BUT I KNEW HER FOR
A SIMILAR AMOUNT OF TIME. AND
WHILE IT WAS LISTED WHAT SHE DID
, IT'S HARD TO REMEMBER THE
TRAILBLAZING THAT WAS GOING ON
WHEN THAT HAPPENED WHEN SHE WAS
ACTIVE IN THE CAUCUS IN THE 19
EIGHTIES, AND IN THE 19
NINETIES, THE NATIONAL PARTY
WOULDN'T EVEN SANCTION IT. IT IT
WAS SOMETHING THAT THAT HAD TO
BE STEPPED UP. I CAN. SHE WAS
ONE OF THE FIRST OUT, DELEGATE
TO MANY OF THE PARTY CONVENTIONS
. AND I RECALL HAVING, UH, SHE
HAD THAT HEART AND SHE HAD THAT
SENSE OF HUMOR SO THAT SHE WAS A
DELEGATE IN 1992 FOR JERRY BROWN
FOR PRESIDENT, AND THE CHANT WAS
TO LET JERRY SPEAK. AND I
REMEMBER I MADE THE MISTAKE OF
WALKING OVER TO SEE HER AND
CHARLIE MCCAIN IN THE DELEGATION
, WEARING A BUTTON OF ANOTHER
CANDIDATE WHEN EVERYBODY STARTED
CHANTING, LET JERRY SPEAK. UH
AND I SAID, IT'S REALLY NICE,
JERRY. THAT A TRIBUTE TO YOU
THAT EVERYBODY WANTS YOU TO
SPEAK. UH UH, SHE LIKED THAT,
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT IT WAS ABOUT
. AND IT IT IS JUST THAT THOSE
QUIET TRAILBLAZERS AT THE TIME
THAT CONVENTION HAPPENED CHARLIE
WAS THE ONE THAT WAS WORKING ON
THE REDISTRICTING FOR SAN DIEGO
THAT LED TO THE SEAT THAT
CHRISTINE KEHOE WON AND PEOPLE
LIKE JERRY WERE AMONG THE
ORGANIZERS IN THE CAMPAIGNS
AMONG THE ACTIVISTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PEOPLE WERE ACTUALLY
ELECTED AND, AS WAS SAID, MANY
OF US ARE HERE. UH UH, FOR THE
WORK THAT WAS DONE THEN, AND SHE
WAS ONE THAT DIDN'T SEEK THE
LIMELIGHT. UNLESS OF COURSE, YOU
WERE TRYING TO TAKE SOME RIGHT
AWAY FROM HER. AND THEN SHE
WOULD BE IN THE FRONT ROW.
STRONG UH UH, WITH A BACKBONE OF
STEEL, AND THAT IS WHY IT IS
SUCH A TRIBUTE TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE HER HERE TODAY. JERRY
DNO, A TRAILBLAZER, A LEADER IN
OUR STATE AND IN SAN DIEGO.
THANK YOU. WE ASK THAT YOU BRING
HER NAME FORWARD SO SHE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. NEXT UP
IS SENATOR HURTADO. THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
STEVE SCHILLING, A VISIONARY
LEADER WHO TRANSFORMED THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. BORN IN 1946.
STEVE'S JOURNEY BEGAN WITH
HUMBLE ROOTS BUT HIS THIRST FOR
KNOWLEDGE AND PASSION FOR
SERVICE PROPELLED HIM FORWARD. A
GRADUATE OF CHICO STATE
UNIVERSITY. STEVE'S EDUCATIONAL
PURSUIT, S¼ LAID THE FOUNDATION
FOR A LIFETIME DEDICATED TO
RURAL DEVELOPMENT AND
HUMANITARIANISM. VENTURING
BEYOND BORDERS. STEVE SPENT 27
MONTHS AS A PEACE CORPS
VOLUNTEER IN VENEZUELA. WHERE HE
EMBRACED DIVERSE CULTURES AND
FORGED BONDS OF UNDERSTANDING.
FOR OVER 45 YEARS, STEVE SERVED
AS A GUIDING FORCE BEHIND
CLINICA, SIERRA VISTA. A BEACON
OF HOPE, PROVIDING HEALTH CARE
ACCESSIBILITY TO ALL IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. UNDER HIS
LEADERSHIP. CLINICA SIERRA VISTA
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE MULTIPLE
HEALTHCARE CENTERS, DENTAL
CLINICS AND A B MEDICAL VAN
SPANNING OVER 1200 SQUARE MILES.
STEVE'S INCLUSIVE APPROACH TO
HEALTH CARE AND UNWAVERING
COMMITMENT TO THE UNDERSERVED
MADE CLINICAS HERE. VISTA ONE OF
THE NATION'S LARGEST COMMUNITY
HEALTH NETWORKS. STEVE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS BELOVED SPOUSE.
THEIR CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN
WHO CARRY ON HIS LEGACY OF
COMPASSION AND SERVICE.
THEREFORE I URGE YOU ALL TO JOIN
ME IN HONORING THE MEMORY OF
STEVE SCHILLING BY JOURNEYING
THIS MEETING IN CELEBRATION OF A
LIFE DEDICATED TO MAKING A
DIFFERENCE. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THE SENATE TO ADJOURN IN
HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
WE EXTEND OUR SINCERE
CONDOLENCES AND ASK THAT YOU
BRING THE NAME FORWARD SO YOU
CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED.
ALL RIGHT. IF THERE'S NÓ OTHER
BUSINESS, SENATOR MCGUIRE OK,
I'M SORRY. I'M GONNA BACK UP FOR
A MINUTE. WE RECOGNIZE TODAY AS
SENATOR HURTADO'S BIRTHDAY.
THEY'RE ALSO WILL BE CAKE IN
ROOM 70 THREE 10 FOR EVERYONE.
EVEN THOSE IN THE GALLERY. COME
GET SOME CAKE. IF THERE'S NÓ
OTHER BUSINESS, SENATOR MAGUIRE
THE DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MR PRESIDENT. HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO CENTER, HER TITLE
AND I'M HOPING IT BUTTER CREAM.
UH, AS THAT IS THE BEST FOR US
IN ON ANY CAKE. UH, THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
THIS. THURSDAY MARCH SEVENTH AT
9 A.M. HAVE A GOOD WEEK MEMBERS.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL 3:30 P.M. AT WHICH TIME AN
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE,
WILL RECONVENE ON THURSDAY AT 9
A.M.